well government workers students and
probably about a total of ten private
sector employees enjoyed the day off
today it's Columbus Day but people are
increasingly not grateful to Christopher
Columbus for giving them the day off
noted fake Native American activist
Elizabeth Warren says today should be
indigenous people day in honor of the
ancestor she doesn't have and more and
more cities across the United States are
renaming the holiday that most notably
Columbus Ohio is ditching Columbus Day
and celebrating Veterans Day instead
James Robbins is the author of erasing
America losing our future by destroying
our past it's a brilliant book based on
a brilliant and true concept he joins us
to me thanks a lot for coming on so this
is part of a larger trend that you write
about in some detail in your book which
I hope our viewers read tell us what
that trend is Tiger well the trend is to
assault the American narrative to make
us all feel ashamed to be Americans to
look at every aspect of the American
story and say you know the founders were
bad the Constitution is racist and what
better place to start them with
Christopher Columbus who is really
patient zero of the European invasion of
America what is I couldn't agree with
you more that's clearly the thread that
ties all these stories together trying
to deal with chittim eyes the country
live in but what's the point of that why
would they want to do that well I think
the point of it is if we feel bad about
our country if we feel bad about the
past then they can rewrite any kind of
future they want
I believe the progressives want to turn
the United States into a socialist
country well in order to do that if you
say that you know the founders were all
evil man and an evil document and
everything in the past was bad well then
they can come up with a future that fits
whatever they want to make it so they're
really telling the rest of us you don't
have the right to defend yourself
against our assault you don't have the
moral legitimacy to defend your own
country oh definitely it's all about
shame it's all about blame you know with
the assault on Columbus and by the way
as a Buckeye I'm really sad about
Columbus Ohio and it ditching the
holiday
I think they should change the name of
the city if that's what they're thinking
but yeah
I agree with that to indigenous city
virtue Vil something like that so are
you seeing this not as obviously it's
been going on academia for quite some
time but it seems to have spread to
again normal places like Columbus Ohio
which is a great town actually filled
with normal people how did it get to
Columbus well I think it's been
insinuated into the American education
system for decades I mean starting in
the 1970s we've had this creep of
revisionism in American history books
until it kind of becomes the accepted
narrative I mean particularly with
Columbus he starts off you know chapter
one and Howard sins revisionist history
of America
so people who've grown up saying
Columbus yeah he's a bad guy that's
unbelievable
it's a great book and your explanation
of it was crisp and super helpful I
appreciate your coming on thank you
thanks doctor